Carlos: Life can change
in a fraction of a second.
Greg: Carlos Ghosn was the best
automotive CEO in the world.
Nick: One of the most
respected business executives
ahead of Bill Gates.
We have reached a new era.
Crowd: Nissan! Nissan!
Nick: It's kind of
the story of Icarus.
The guy soared
to the highest of highs.
Probably too high.
News: Breaking news…
Carlos Ghosn has been arrested
in Japan.
Hiroto: There were many
serious wrongdoings.
News: Money laundering
and corruption.
News: Ghosn faces a maximum
penalty of 10 years imprisonment.
News: Is Carlos Ghosn a victim?
Or a villain?
♪
Now I'm gonna surprise you.
Nick: There was
tons of evidence.
This hard drive is the key
to the entire Ghosn story.
Robert: He called
a former Green Beret.
The plan was
to put him in a box
and drill holes
so he could breathe.
Carole: This story is much
bigger than we think it is.
Nick: We only knew
one side of Carlos Ghosn.
Michael: He gets caught…
he loses his life.
Richard: Why did you do it?
There was no turning back.
They tried to destroy me.
♪
Michael: Life's got a lot
of strange twists and turns.